for most of history
religion has been a central focus of
human concerns
but now in large parts of the developed
world it's become a sideshow
or even an irrelevance because it's been
declared untrue
by the most powerful force of our age
science
but debating whether religion is true or
not may not in the end be the most
important move we can make it's also key
to understand what needs
have traditionally driven people to
religion so we can go on recognizing and
answering these needs
even outside a supernatural structure
4000 bc arnhem land australia
an aboriginal australian paints an image
of a serpent on a rock
the so-called yengana serpent is a key
part of aboriginal religion
this creature and a few other associated
divine serpents
are worshiped for having done everything
created the sky the lagoons the
mountains
they colored the birds they decreed laws
relating to marriage
food distribution and death ceremonies
the serpents also generate
rain and storms when anyone breaks the
rules of the tribes
the belief structure of the early
australians is almost identical to that
found in primitive religions
pretty much everywhere around our planet
religion has its origins in a desire to
explain
a very confusing world it is a wild
projection onto the natural realm
of all kinds of human concerns it
becomes the focus of rituals
to appease the possibly angry gods
offerings are made in return one hopes
for favors and kindness always there is
the terror of death
and the hope that the worst of it can be
handled by an alliance with the gods
one comes away from the study of
primitive religions full of compassion
for the terrors and confusion
that were responsible for generating
these beliefs and for the frightening
ignorance in which our forbearers
were fated to live but one also comes
away with respect for our own
psychological ingenuity
for our cleverness in telling ourselves
stories to calm ourselves down
hold the community together and deal
with the unknown
400 bc kushinagar india a kind
philosophical indian prince
siddhartha gautama meets his end his
other title
buddha means awakened or enlightened one
he teaches his followers of whom there
will soon be millions
to expect constant suffering in life but
also
to strive to detach themselves from
their immediate circumstances
and the anxious spasms of what buddhists
call the monkey mind
through reflection and meditation in
buddhism we see a characteristic attempt
of religion
to calm the minds of followers in
relation to anxiety
poverty illness and death the task of
religion is to keep us hopeful
to stop our minds caving into terror and
to hold our hands
through the worst last days of our lives
10 25 a.d song dynasty china
a sculptor produces this representation
of a beautiful
kindly female buddhist deity called
guanyin
guan yin is the buddhist counterpart of
the virgin mary
and she fulfills a similar role as this
lady
that of hearing us in our distress
meeting us with tenderness
and strengthening us to face the tasks
of life
the centrality of these maternal figures
in both buddhism and christianity
suggests that mature adult lives share
moments of
terrible and lacerating self-doubt which
breed longings to recover some of the
security and coziness
of childhood being reasonable and adult
doesn't always work in our worst crises
we regress
we want to be held and understood and
forgiven like we were five years old
all this religion knows honours and does
not mock us for
1133 winchester england
the poorest people in the parish of
winchester in southern england
take up residence in the hospital of
saint cross and the arms house of noble
poverty
this is the oldest charitable
institution in the united kingdom
founded by the bishop of winchester who
has read the gospels thoroughly and
taken inspiration
from jesus's command to treat the
poorest with special dignity
though destined for the poorest the arms
houses are built on the scale of an
oxford or cambridge college with the
most beautiful noble architecture of the
day
the arms houses are a typical example of
a theme found in all world religions
that of charity and of the duty of the
rich towards the poor
though there may be a regressive aspect
to this religions can be praised for
moderating egoistic impulses
and urging the powerful to think of the
defenseless
it can be tempting to think of the poor
as evil and responsible for their fate
but religions ask the powerful to
imagine them always as unfortunate and
worthy of a special place
in the divine scheme 1543
nuremberg germany nicolas copernicus
publishes on the revolutions of the
celestial spheres
this posts a heliocentric view of the
universe rather than geocentric version
widely accepted at the time and based on
the book of joshua
in 1616 the catholic church moves to
declare this heliocentric theory
nonsense and angrily bans copernicus's
work
however copernicus's revolution will not
be quelled
galileo galilei will defend the system
in a dialogue on the two chief world
systems published in 1632
again the papacy is furious it curses
copernicus once more and puts galileo
under house arrest
it's tempting to laugh at the catholic
church but the church is trying to hold
on to something rather lovely
that had served humankind well the idea
of our cosmic significance the idea that
we matter
that someone out there cares copernicus
and galileo's theories
are like the very painful end of the
childhood of mankind
their discoveries that we are but a tiny
forgotten meaningless blue dot
in the randomness of space is akin to a
child discovering that his or her
parents are in truth
really unimportant in the scheme of
things a new existential terror
will echo down the ages from these
scientific discoveries
we are still dealing with it july 1830
london england charles lyle publishes
the first of three volumes of his
geological masterpiece
principles of geology the book uses new
geological methods
to show that the earth is far older than
was ever previously believed
the bible had said it was six thousand
years old lyle says the fossil record
proves it must be at least
240 million years old based on his
observation of marine fossils
modern science now puts it at 4.5
billion years
in response to lyle's discoveries the
british social critic and essayist john
ruskin
abandons belief he says his faith has
been beaten to the thinness of gold leaf
by such rock bound evidence if only the
geologist would leave me alone he writes
i could do very well but those dreadful
hammers
i hear the clink of them at the end of
every cadence of the bible verses
science now makes it almost impossible
for any intelligent person to believe in
the bible as literally true
1835 tubing in germany 27 year old david
friedrich strauss
publishes the first edition of the first
volume of an epochal work
the life of jesus critically examined
strauss advances the view
that it doesn't matter whether or not
christ really was the son of god
or worked miracles or came back from the
dead after being crucified
because what's important about him is
the moral example he gives
his generosity his immense tenderness to
the weak
his commitment to forgiveness you must
forgive your brother
seven times seventy he notes his
humility he lived as a carpenter had a
simple life
lived amongst the poor strauss initiates
a new way of looking at religion
it isn't a true description of how the
world actually
is it's something humans have invented
to comfort themselves
in highly valuable and important ways
that deserve our selective
reverence 1885 amsterdam netherlands
a new national museum the reichs museum
officially opens
the architect pierre koipes has spent
his career designing and restoring
churches
and it shows the building is quickly
dubbed a new cathedral
devoted to art with its stained glass
and ecclesiastical solemnity
the museum is one of many to open in the
second part of the 19th century
it's the result of a widespread panic as
to what can replace religion
now that belief is in decline one
leading answer
is that culture can replace scripture
the argument is that art can achieve for
us many of the things that religion once
did
it can be a guide a source of
consolation a teacher of wisdom and
compassion
a reminder of our better nature and
something that can
imperfectly but still to a real extent
reconcile us to our mortality
2006 oxford england an english biologist
richard dawkins publishes
the god delusion dawkins argues that
religion is intellectually wrong
and delusional and therefore should be
removed entirely from public culture
though dawkins just about stops from
saying that people should be prevented
by law from being religious
in private but only just dawkins's
mocking view of religion
coincides with deep disquiet about
militant islam in the west
the murderous ways of fringe muslim
groups seems to be dawkins's real target
religion just comes to seem like
something a bunch of mad people
could ever be interested in dawkins
insists that reasonable people
can find all the consolation they need
in science and medicine
the doctor can replace the priest the
welfare state can replace
charity and the laboratory can replace
rituals and ceremonies
for the rest we have television and the
news
the needs that religions answered were
real and important and despite science
and tv
and theme parks and cancer treatment
centers we still have many of these
needs
we still have to die we still need to be
comforted we still need to be reminded
in conditions of aggressive capitalism
of our duties to the community and to
the poor and we still need somewhere to
take our disappointed ambitions
frustrations and sorrows religion may
well have been
a deep illusion but it was an important
illusion
that we need to understand with sincere
depth and compassion
in order to know how to create
functioning secular societies
in our own time
you